I speak to a lot of people who start off
YouTube channels and then you know they
started off thinking it's not really
going to go anywhere but then it goes
somewhere and they're like oh my
goodness like this thing has gone
somewhere and then when when they start
to treat it as a business it starts to
be hard and they start to think oh my
God I must be bad I must be an idiot
because I'm finding this hard and I was
trying to be like no no it's like this
is business it's it's supposed to be
hard something you said there just
reminded me that I actually think a lot
of people think they're scared of
failure but I think a lot of people are
actually scared of success what do you
mean because I think scared that they'll
reach a level of success like you said
building a YouTube channel and it's
suddenly taking off and I think they'll
believe that they won't be able to
handle it and they'll have to cope with
new things that they don't know they can
cope with and they have to they have to
change as well and if they change other
people who are in their safe secure
bubble right now might reject them or
might not like them or might think that
they've got too big for their boots or
something like that I think that people
are more scared of success than they
actually realize